daisy
[Music]
oh wow it's so nice here
it's almost messed up how nice it is
like i knew i wouldn't have graffiti
but i think that's a banksy hi uh are
you mac
i think you're my bayside buddy you're
supposed to show me around
oh awesome hey would you be able to lay
down in the parking spot overnight so my
friend in me can't park into tomorrow
time out what did that blonde fool just
say to me
hi daisy they accidentally put me in
regular english last week but not where
i belong in a class of fellow high
achievers
hey buddy wait you're an honors english
duh it's an honor to teach me before we
start i'm gonna collect your summer
reading assignments
wait summer reading no one told me about
summer reading
okay i didn't know we had an assignment
but if you could give me a one day
extension i could read the whole book
tonight and hand in my report first
thing tomorrow morning what don't be
silly no one expects you to do that
i'm not asking for special treatment i
can do the work
daisy this is honors english i think
you'll find it plenty hard without
taking on
extra assignments time out she obviously
thinks i can't do it but no need to
freak out
i'm cool i just don't want you to
struggle to catch up
you couldn't possibly be don't tell me
what i'm possible of
sure why don't you do the assignment
sounds great
good morning joyce white lady
it's pronounced wit liddy what's your
name girlfriend
um i'm daisy jimenez you might have
heard of me i'm class president
you are oh good for you
time out now i've met a lot of joyce
white ladies in my life
she has good intentions but she's gonna
make me feel like crap like by trying to
bond with me by saying something she
heard a black guy say on project runway
okay here's the t-assist
hey you look rough i stood up all night
working on my report
but i'm almost done if i can convince my
bio teacher that i have diarrhea
i can hide in the bathroom all first
period and finish did i hear diarrhea
we can get you medicine if you don't
have insurance i'm fine oh please we
really want to help
we have typing classes prom dresses cans
of corn
please oh long story short i faked my
own death and hooked up with the hot
mortician
listen i've loved all 87 of these
stories but can you please just tell me
where i can get my textbooks
yeah we're here based out is 99
paperless so getting your books is kind
of a pain in the ass
ugh it took forever but what if i don't
have one of those what if i can't do a
poo poo
don't have what is what is that
look i know that this school has
problems but it's our first day
exactly and it's already unfair if you
don't have an ipad if you ride the bus
if you're not one of them you're set up
to fail we need someone to fight for us
who knows us
that's why i have to be student council
president now more than ever
but you know your posters have to be in
by tomorrow what who said
uh they sent out a message about it on
the bayside student app what the hell is
a bayside student at
you see we're set up to fail you know
some of us don't have smartphones
because their moms say they're too
expensive and
almenos puedo tomar photos
i hate this school and i hate this phone
it's okay i worked hard on my posters
i'm still gonna put up my posters
hey where can i put up my posters hold
on braun braun
did you not reserve wall space in the
bayside student now
if you can make it one week without
hitting on bayside i'll give you 50
bucks
oh i've been hanging out with too many
rich kids i'll give you 50 cents
deal deal hey ladies i just met the
hottest
girl her name's pamela and she's a
perfect 10.
i mean blonde hair gorgeous smile and
she just had really bad mono so you know
she does tongues
hmm well what do you think about that
daisy yeah
i think it's cool congratulations on
your new love guys i just met the girl
of my dreams
blonde hair killer smile recently sick
it's the same girl wait yo jay dog you
also met a hot bomb this morning
that's right do you think
we should both ask our separate girls
with ice cream friday night
yes
time out frankenstein a report by mack
morris
whoa frankenstein is a story of a man
who creates a creature in his own image
my father and i oh my god
i mean he built on the mid-sentence and
he clearly needs a billion dollars of
therapy but
he actually listened to me if mac morris
can change what up oh stupido not racist
i call my mom that
hey that thing i was saying the other
day about how nobody expects anything
from you
i hate that feeling and i shouldn't have
tried to make you feel it too
daisy it means a lot to me
now that you want a romantic
relationship okay nope
goodbye i just think we're better as
friends
i'm sorry you feel the opposite rule
number one is spending money like a rich
person
we can do better
[Music]
no we can do better
we can do better
we can do better we can do even better
[Music]
hello service um
i don't work here oh
i know snapping is rude i'm being a rich
person don't judge me
do you remember in middle school when
you got your braids done for class
pictures
and you wanted to add pink hair you
didn't because you thought it looked too
ghetto
but then our teacher missed once
freaking miss winston
right she called your regular
not pink braids ghetto anyway sometimes
people are just
miss winston's some of the bayside kids
are gonna paint all the douglas kids
with the same brush no matter what we do
devonte did a bad thing but you're
blaming him for how those other kids are
making you feel
daisy i get that you're worried about
college but you have way too many
extracurriculars you're president of the
science club
and the flat earth society there's two
sides to every story and maybe just
maybe two sides to this earth
right daisy colleges are not impressed
by how many random clubs you join
they want to know who you are a fun
normal teen who hasn't had a moment of
relaxation since first grade
no you are student council president
a leader focus on that there's actually
a very competitive summer leadership
program i think you'd be
perfect for it's eight weeks of seminars
hosted by
inspirational women last year's keynote
address was delivered
in unison by the cast of big little lies
oh my god
that sounds amazing and it's a
fellowship which means
all expenses paid including lodging and
airfare to new york
plus a per diem for bagels but
i can't be away from my family for that
long oh
i get it my husband's been in arizona
for the past three months on a writer's
retreat and
it's tough it's not about missing them
my mom needs me to babysit my brother
and i usually get a summer job
uh well that's different
daisy i don't know anything about your
family situation
but i do know about being a mom and all
moms want the best for their kids future
just talk to her look over the
application together and maybe she'll
sign the permission slip
or what if instead i threw the
application into the win and if she
finds it it's god's will
you